she's the Oscar nominee for her role in
the winter soil he's the star of Bob
Robertson the Flyers Susan Sarandon and
Tim Robbins
in the spirit of the red ribbons being
worn here this evening we'd like to call
attention to 266 Haitians that are being
held in Guantanamo Bay by the United
States government their crime testing
positive to the HIV virus and their
behalf and all the people living with
HIV in this country we would like to ask
our governing officials in Washington to
admit that HIV is not a crime and to
admit these people into the United
States thank you
which brings us of course to editing
in our movie theaters there are some
pictures we watch and others we
experience both are cut from the same
materials and it's the film editors who
do the cutting in the early days of
making movies that was considered menial
work and it was left to the girls in the
splicing room where they followed
directors orders one of which was to
remain as invisible as their splices
but smart gifted women like Viola
Lawrence emerged to elevate the cutters
tray to the craft of editing in 1934 the
Academy created the best editing
category and Bach ins nomination marked
the rise of the splicing moon girls to
womanhood and full collaboration and
filming six years later she edited
Northwest Mounted Police and was honored
with an Oscar since then a lot of other
women have nurtured nourished and shaped
many of the movies we've seen here are
just a few of those we've experienced
all of which were edited by women who
worked alone or teamed with men as
equals
the nominees for film editing are Frank
J Yuri Oh Steve for Basic Instinct
pant pan for The Crying Game
Robert Leighton for a few good men
Geraldine Peroni for the player and Joel
Cox for Unforgiven and the Oscar goes to
Joel Cox for Unforgiven
thank you
32 years ago when I started the mailroom
at Warner Brothers I never dreamed I'd
be standing here tonight I thank you for
this honor I share this honor this award
when the cast and crew of Unforgiven
David Valdes Michael seprieono my
assistant
well I the entire mal Paso family Warner
Brothers especially to my wife Judy my
children my heart is pounding it's
something I thank you
I just Clint thank you for 18 years of
friendship and support may God bless
each and every one of you thank you very
much
you know was interesting was one of the
editors names was can't pan it's
interesting wanted to be a cameraman
obviously blue and I said watch your
name e1 can't pan is it won't try
editing and I guess maybe that's how
that happening is Alencar producing the
show again each year